now we've understandably talked a lot
today about the future of the prime
minister and party politics in
westminster
but believe it or not there are other
very very significant things happening
abroad right now
the pentagon says russia is planning to
fabricate attacks as a pretext to invade
ukraine
again
russia's dismissed the claims of course
but has a hundred thousand troops on the
ukrainian border and talked between
moscow and nato ended in failure this
week earlier i spoke to kurt volker
formerly the u.s ambassador to nato and
the special representative to ukraine
he's worked under presidents bush obama
and trump
i started by asking him how dangerous he
thinks the situation is
i think it is very real um very
dangerous probably the most dangerous it
has been since the last time russia
invaded which is 2014.
you remember then that
russia in stealthily went into crimea
used little green men and special forces
took over crimea did the same thing
again in eastern ukraine and there's now
been a war going on at a very low level
for seven years about 14 000 people have
been killed on the ukrainian side but it
appears as though putin has put in place
all of the forces necessary to launch a
fresh new large invasion
and he is making all kinds of threats to
the west and to nato that if he doesn't
get some kind of guarantee about
ukraine being under russia's fear of
influence he's going to do it again
it um it's thought unlikely that he
would simply march across the border the
pentagon
says that russia is planning a so-called
false flag attack to fabricate fabricate
a reason to invade um
do you think that's how this kind of
thing starts
um it can
it's not the only way but i think it can
i think what putin was attempting to do
or what the pentagon is saying he was
attempting to do was have russian
special forces uh acting as though they
were ukrainians attacking the
russian-led forces in eastern ukraine in
order to give them a reason to come back
and attack those forces and go massively
into ukraine that's one way to get this
started there might be other ways as
well if you remember in 2014
russia used
regular military and special forces in
unmarked uniforms to take over
government buildings and declare an
insurrection and then when ukraine tried
to put down the insurrection massively
slowed in so-called humanitarian
assistance which turned out to be a lot
of weaponry and a lot of troops
but i think that sort of thing softening
up the target creating the pretext it's
also why he wanted to have these
meetings with the us and nato to get a
rejection of his ideas he's trying to
create the pretext for
justifying uh
going into ukraine again so that's how
you read the talks in vienna this week
which seem
frankly forgot nowhere
yes and i think entirely predictable
putin knew that the demands that he put
into the texts that he gave to the us
and nato in december would be absolutely
unacceptable uh nato is not going to say
no countries can ever join again uh nato
is not going to say that we will
withdraw
our military protection of the baltic
states and poland
nato is not going to say that russia has
a right to determine the
future and security aspirations of its
neighbors
knowing that why would he then propose
these things
i think on the one hand of course if we
were to give him that he'd be happy
but more realistically he knew he would
get a rejection and he wanted to show
that he made the effort at dialogue and
diplomacy but he was rejected so
he quote unquote had no choice
there's been a lot of activity this week
um
ukraine was hit by a massive cyber
attack warning its citizens to be
quite afraid and expect the worst now um
we don't know who exactly is behind that
attack but if it does turn out to be
a russian or russian inspired um because
you've seen something similar in the
past um
what action could be taken
well first off let's analyze that attack
a little bit it um
there have been cyber attacks against
ukraine against estonia uh in the united
states against our election system in
germany even in the uk i believe so
it would be fitting the pattern for this
to be russia and surprising if it's not
second what is the message here it is
psychological pressure on ukraine we can
attack your government ministries
anytime we want to we can put up our
messages on those ministries and we only
did the civilian ones this time we
didn't do your military the implicit
threat being we can do your military so
i think this is a lot of psychological
pressure on ukraine as far as what can
be done about cyber attacks it's it's
probably too late to prevent things now
it is something that all of us need to
do in in the west in ukraine in our
partner countries help them build
resilience against cyber attacks uh but
it's something that needs to be done
constantly and with vigilance not
something that at the spur of the moment
we can change mr putin has masked a
hundred thousand russian troops on the
border he says
i can do what i like on my own
soil
but uh it's evident that this is at some
level
um a kind of intimidation what do you
think is larger game is here what is
what is the point of all of this
well i think
it is what he said it is
which is uh he wants to prevent ukraine
from ever being admitted to nato he
wants nato to basically agree to tear up
the helsinki accords and this idea that
every state has a right to its
sovereignty and territorial integrity
every state can choose its own alliances
this foundation of security in europe
that's been in place for 50 years he
wants to tear that up and replace it
with something more like yalta which is
there's an eastern sphere of influence
and that's ours and there's a western
sphere of influence you can play there
and this is a deal between stalin and uh
western leaders correct yes he's looking
to go back to that as opposed to the
arrangements for european security that
have been in place for decades and i
would connect this to a vision that he
has uh remember he was a kgb officer in
eastern germany uh he was deeply
disappointed with the fall of the soviet
union called it the greatest tragedy of
the 20th century and believed that it
was the fault of the leaders of the
soviet union at that time to allow that
to happen
i think he sees himself in the mode of a
builder of the greater russia and he
seeks to acquire territories as he's
done already with crimea or occupies
parts of ukraine georgia or the soft
takeover he's done in belarus and
possibly even now in kazakhstan so i
think he sees himself as reassembling
the pieces of a greater russia and this
happens of course in the anniversary
year of the founding of the soviet union
i think he'd like to emerge from this
year having shown that he has built
something big
let's get to the sharp end of this
you've spent a lot of time
in talks with russians who've been uh
involved uh in the politics of the
ukraine for
many years
do you think
in reality that
it is a real possibility that he could
invade
yes yes i would say that
my way of looking at it is more likely
than not
his rhetoric has escalated to a point
that will make it very hard not to
follow through
it is clear that the west cannot give
him the the guarantees and demands that
he is seeking and i think that he
actually will want to make some kind of
invasion some kind of territorial
acquisition but he'll want to do it
swiftly he'll want to stop within a
short period of time and then try to
connect these territories of crimea and
donbass and maybe other parts of ukraine
and make them part of what is a sphere
of influence for russia by action since
he's not going to get that by words from
nato or the us well you say he won't get
it by words so what can nato and the us
do for example there i guess there's
some people who think that maybe to
accede to the demand that ukraine would
never join nato
would be one way of at least getting him
back to the negotiating table
well what it would do is it would give
him something and cause him to think
well what else should i be getting as
well he's not going to stop with getting
his demands met we've seen this this
movie many times
and moreover it is not for us to sign
away the rights of 40 million ukrainians
it is for them to decide the future of
their own country now what the u.s and
europe are doing
is threatening massive retaliatory
sanctions if russia does invade again
increasing these military presence in
nato allies in eastern europe and
increasing security assistance to
ukraine so they can better defend
themselves but all of this is being
framed as a response if russia attacks
again
and i think that what we really should
be doing is taking the all three of
those steps but doing it right away as a
deterrent to such an invasion with a
promise that we could wind down some of
that if russia stands its forces down
and we're no longer negotiating under
the threat of the use of force so you
would stand
next to former secretary of state uh
mike pompeo when he criticizes the biden
administration
for basically talking and not doing um
because uh
pompeo has said that putin is prepared
to
push to the brink is it his expression
in ukraine to get what he wants you are
in favor
of more aggressive tactics
well i wouldn't describe what i said as
aggressive uh i do believe that we need
to be doing rather than talking only
and i think that that he's right about
that but helping a country get the
armaments and training so it can defend
itself is not an aggressive step uh it
is a prudent one to help stave off such
an invasion putting sanctions against a
country that is now using extortionist
type threats against nato against
ukraine against europe um that's not an
unreasonable thing to do either and we'd
be willing to lift those sanctions if
russia stopped its intimidating activity
i don't see these as aggressive moves i
see them as prudent defensive moves to
put in place to try to stave off
something worse
i was interested in the pompeo
intervention is this a sign uh that mr
pompeo is now gearing up for a run in
2024 is this the opening
of the political hostilities
for um the elections
in states later on this year and then
the 2024 uh presidential election yeah i
read an article yesterday
where there was a debate about when did
the 2024 presidential election campaign
begin is it 2022 was it in 2020 just
after the january 6th riots or did it
actually begin in 2020 before the 2020
election and people are already jostling
for 2024. um i think it may have been
the latter as well too
uh
no one knows at this stage who is going
to run on the republican side it is
quite possible that former president
trump would run again there are a number
of strong republican candidates mike
pompeo among them who might want to try
as well
a lot of them are doing the kinds of
things you need to do to prepare so they
can make a decision later if they choose
to run
and i think mike pompeo would be one of
the stronger candidates if he did